I'm John Owens.
I'm an Associate Professor of Electrical and Computer Engineering at UC Davis,
where I lead a group of amazing graduate students in exploring the frontiers of GPU computing.
And I'm Dave Luebke. I'm a Senior Director of Research at Nvidia where I study 3D graphics,
and I've been working with John and others for many years on expanding the reach of GPUs.
This class focuses on parallel computing on the GPU.
You'll learn about both the hardware and the software on the modern GPU,
and get to work with high end GPUs as you develop a set of image processing tools during the assignments,
such as those that you might find in cool applications such as Photoshop or Instagram.
We think that projects will be both interesting and fun.
But most important, you'll learn how to think about computing in a parallel way.
Thinking in parallel is a crucial skill,
maybe even the crucial skill as you approach challenging problems in all areas of computing.
All right. So let's get started.